this sunday we are hosting the 22nd
annual a home for the holidays on cbs
this special brings awareness to the
thousands of children in foster care
across the country
and shares the uplifting stories of
children who are adopted into loving
homes
this year jason and chad watkins
describe seeing their son
for the very first time i'm at work i
rush home
i call grandma and then a car pulls up
chad was so excited he just runs out the
door
and i see this little boy asleep in the
car seat
and i pick him up and he just grabbed on
to me and i said
you're home you're home now you're safe
our bond happened instantaneously
well you're home you're safe something
we take for granted a lot of us there
will also be special performances
from artists like josh groban love him
miranda lambert love her andrea buchelli
love him and leslie odom jr love him too
[Music]
i just love that listen that song is
called heaven and earth
you've got to go online and listen to it
better yet by leslie's album it's really
great
heaven and earth is an original track
from his newest release the christmas
album and guess who joins us right now
leslie odom jr hello leslie it's so good
to see you
last time you were here at the table we
miss you but we all understand the
circumstances
so this special let's talk about it
we're going to see three
virtual online adoptions right on camera
this certainly does tug at the
heartstrings when you watch it
do you have a personal connection to the
story are you just thinking
i like the special i want to be a part
of it
i have two little nephews that came
through the foster care system and
um and so my you know my dear friends
that have adopted their children that
way
i've been talking for years about the
way that
americans they really wish that we
thought of all the ways to expand our
families
you know a lot of people go through
great lengths to have children
on their own which of course you know is
an option that's available to you
but this is something else it's a viable
option and a way to
to help the 400 000 kids we have in the
foster care system
here in america leslie they call it a
forever home when you move from the
foster care system
into a permanent family uh how does life
change other than the address
uh for kids how do their prospects
change when they make that transition
oh i mean i can only imagine um
personally you know these these are
still very little kids that that are
a part of our family and all i can see
is that you know
they they came together in a different
way than certainly
uh nicolette and i have expanded our
family but
they're no different you know um these
kids uh
are thriving in in their new forever
home
did you just say you and your lovely
wife nicolette have expanded your family
i was gonna ask
what are you doing in the time of
quarantine but now i think i'll see
i hears and then you guys you and listen
nicolette is great she can also she's
got a beautiful voice
you all did the series love and the time
of corona which was great there she is
holding her tummy baby number two
is on the way when's baby number two
coming to join lucy that's right
we got yeah we got a little boy coming
in march we have a little boy oh that's
really exciting
a lot of a lot of people of your stature
say that they've become more creative
during this
time is that has that happened to you
too during the pandemic
i don't know if it's been i don't know
if i'm more creative
but you know i have the limits of these
this little rectangle
you know so i've i've been
you know i've gotten creative within the
confines
um and we've we've tried to innovate and
and stay creative in this time my
favorite thing is
when i can feel useful so much of what i
do
you know can feel superfluous or silly
from time to time so when i can feel
useful like a
like a home for the holiday special or
to make this christmas album
you know when i hope it's just an
offering of joy at the end of a really
challenging year that's my favorite
thing
yeah i want to talk about the christmas
hell because i was listening to it last
weekend it is
just beautiful and i've heard artists
say you know it's not as easy to make a
christmas album as you might think
no no well because you are uh there is
there's a tradition there is a tradition
um
of really fantastic music that is dear
to us
yeah you know for for generations and so
um you need to if you want to attempt to
write new
christmas classics which we did for the
very first time on this record yeah and
heaven on earth is stunning
stunning thank you it is you need to
write something that can
you know sit side by side with some of
the most beloved songs
of all time yeah mission accomplished
there's a lot of oscar buzz for you
mr leslie for your original song in the
film it is
i want to get the name right one night
in miami right you
you play legendary sam cook is an oscar
something you even dare to go there and
think about because listen
you've got if you win an oscar you'd be
an emmy
you've already you've already got you've
already got this you've already got the
grammy and the tony sorry
is an offer something you even dream to
think about what did you think of your
performance in one night in miami what'd
you think
oh man i well you know what i i can
i i always watch myself
and i'll say this by the end of one
night of miami i was like this you know
so
that's that's the most i can give myself
i opened the crack a little bit i was
you know
now i mean we we regina king
as a director you know what i can say is
that
she made me better uh you know whenever
she came and had a thought
or a suggestion for me she always made
me better
and you love the film you love the film
i really do i think it's very special i
do
um and when that happens it's a miracle
because it's such a collaborative art
form so
so many things have to come together to
to make something that's
that is this um special is rare
i i can't wait to see it leslie i love
what you said regina king made me better
so
note to yourself that's what women's do
we make you men's is better
so congratulations that is the note let
me write it down
write it down happy holidays to you and
your lovely nicolette and lucy and the
baby on the way always good to see you
thank you thank you so much
can't wait to come back to the table the
22nd annual a home for the holidays airs
is sunday night
right here on cbs